what would you want to see in a hogwarts
legacy collector's edition
for a franchise as big as harry potter i
feel pretty confident hogwarts legacy
will see at least some form of a
collector's or
special edition all of this of course
when the game launches in
2022 in today's video i'll give you 10
of my favorite ideas for items that
could be included in a hogwarts legacy
collector's edition
also i'll explain why i don't want to
see a wand as part of the package
people love the internet retro racking
tour here and i'm just a dad who loves
games and the stories they tell
we post videos every week here on
youtube and if you want to stay up to
date on all the latest news theories and
discussion regarding hogwarts legacy
then consider subscribing to the channel
and ringing the bell so you don't miss
any of our new videos
video game collector's editions have
grown in popularity over the years and
now it seems
few major games release without one i
know everyone has their own ideas about
what makes a good collector's edition
but for me there are a few things i like
to see now i certainly don't expect a
hogwarts legacy edition to include all
10 items on this list
we'd probably only see a handful of
these items in a package that includes
the game as well of course
for starters though i want to see at
least one item that i can actually
use collectibles figurines they're all
well and good but i prefer the package
include at least
one item that i can use in my everyday
life honestly i
really don't purchase collector's
editions too often but two of my
favorites that i
did end up purchasing number one is the
infamous two collectors edition
and number two is the persona 5
collector's edition
one thing these both had in common is
that they included a bag and i still
have both of them and still
use them even today i'm particularly
fond of the infamous backpack which i
take to work every day and on trips to
hold my electronics
it's of a pretty solid build quality and
has actually held up quite well over all
these years so for number one how about
a hogwarts
storage trunk if any of you out there
own the harry potter
cover boxed set then this idea will be
very familiar to you as that box
set came inside a harry potter storage
trunk now for hogwarts legacy i'd like
to see something that's much
better in quality something closer to
this trunk that you can get from the
pottery barn's online
store they actually have a ton of cool
harry potter items not
sponsored at all by the way i've just
admired their stuff over the years and
have a few items from there of part of
my own collection
this specific trunk that you're seeing
right now actually retails for 350
dollars so it's pretty high quality but
it's also quite
large as you can see in this picture
here now hogwarts legacy could do a much
smaller version of this and even then
it's probably unlikely we'd get
something
that fancy i do think this at least
gives you an idea of what i'm talking
about in terms of a
nice little storage trunk though moving
on to number two i'd love to see a map
of the hogwarts grounds at first i
thought maybe it'd be cool if it
included a map of hogwarts itself but
that would probably prove way too
complex
and then you've got the marauders map
which hadn't been created by the late
1800s time frame in which hogwarts
legacy is set to take place
that being said i think a map of the
grounds would be a fun collectible that
could also be useful to help you
navigate in game i remember red dead
redemption actually packaged a map
inside the regular game as part of the
instruction manual and i really loved
having that
i want to say skyrim did something
similar as well maybe i'm thinking about
another game but i know
hogwarts legacy certainly wouldn't be
the first game to do this for number
three it's true you have to have at
least one collectible trinket type item
in the package and for hogwarts legacy i
would expect at least a few of the
collectibles to be focused on
magical creatures the magical creatures
of the wizarding world have been a
consistent presence in
all of the official material released
about the game from the trailer to the
concept art to the faq
it's clear magical creatures are going
to play a prominent role
with all the magical creatures in the
wizarding world there are numerous
ways they could go with this but i'm
going to go with one of my favorite
creatures in
all of fantasy really and that is a
dragon
i think a dragon statue would be really
fun here maybe they could even
incorporate hogwarts somehow and have
the dragon
flying above like we see in the initial
reveal trailer now almost
any collector's edition out there will
include a soundtrack so that is my
suggestion for number four
the official hogwarts legacy soundtrack
the harry potter series has been
known to have fantastic music throughout
all of the movies and even in the video
games as well
one of the best things about the
hogwarts legacy trailer was the great
music it was really nice and i fully
expect the game to blow
us away when it comes to the music
department
[Applause]
[Music]
so of course we need a full copy to keep
for ourselves and i think it makes
perfect sense to have it as part of a
collector's edition
all right halfway through here and at
number five i'm gonna throw out another
useful item for my suggestion and that
is a hogwarts
satchel or kind of like a tote bag i
talked in the beginning about how i
still use that persona 5 bag and my
infamous backpack so it only makes sense
that i'd like to see
one in hogwarts legacy as well at first
i thought about including house themed
items on the list but with four
different houses i just can't see them
making
four different collectors editions with
a focus on each house
don't get me wrong it'd absolutely be
amazing if they did that but i just
can't see it happening
instead i think it would be smart of
them to focus on items that feature kind
of hogwarts overall
as a school and maybe even the crest
showcasing all four of the houses
at number six no enrollment at hogwarts
is complete without an official
acceptance letter
this would certainly be a smaller item
that could even fit inside the standard
game box but i think it would be a
really nice touch if they included a
little acceptance letter to welcome us
to hogwarts for an
added twist maybe the acceptance letter
could even explain part of the game's
storyline and why we are receiving a
late acceptance letter if you didn't
already know about this it's actually
been confirmed by avalanche that we'll
be starting the game in year five
after receiving a late letter and
personally i really
really want to know why moving on to
number seven one of the items on every
student's supply list is a quill
and parchment i've always wanted to
write with an actual quill and i'm not
talking about a quill that's actually
just a pin
i mean a actual ink bottle and quill
talk about an authentic collector's
edition i'd be blown away if they
managed to include a real quill with a
tiny little bottle of ink
that being said i realized that setting
the bar may be a little bit too high
and truthfully i'd still be happy with
the package that included a quill that's
really just a pin
for number eight i'm gonna suggest
another standard one but one that i
think would be really awesome for
hogwarts legacy and that is an
art book i know i know we see these in
all the collector's editions but just
imagine
how excited we got over four pieces of
concept art that were just released
and in fact really only three one of
them was just kind of the hogwarts house
crests
those three pieces alone have me super
excited for a potential art book i i
really want to see the thought process
and what all of the avalanche artists
have been working on
all this time in preparing for this game
the ones we've seen so far have all been
so incredibly well done and i just know
avalanche has to be sitting on a trove
of pieces
from magical creatures to wands to the
school itself
number nine on our list and once we have
our hogwarts acceptance letter we'll
also need our ticket to platform nine
and three quarters look i know this is a
smaller item but the truth is you're
gonna need some smaller items to kind of
balance out the overall collector's
edition package
anyway you can't have super extravagant
items be the whole thing i mean again
i'd love it but that's just not how
these collector's editions work
a hogwarts acceptance letter paired with
a platform ticket could be the extra
icing on the cake
avalanche could even take this a step
further by having both documents and
maybe a little small
collectible frame or a really nice
sleeve so you can display them together
at number 10 here on our list i'm going
with another big idea
how about a super useful item that would
also fit with heading off to hogwarts
for the start of a new term
how about a hogwarts themed suitcase
like number one on our list the pottery
barn has some incredible harry potter
themed items on that front
they have these right here and they
actually have them for each of the four
houses
now i don't own any of these personally
so i can't speak to their quality but
from what i can see in the images and
reading the description
these appear to have plenty of features
and compartments and i
really love that they have the little
spinner wheels at the bottom always love
seeing people going around the airport
with those little spinning wheels
now in the beginning i mentioned that i
don't want to see a wand as part of the
package and i know that's probably going
to be a thing that a lot of you suggest
but here's why i don't really want to
see it here mainly it's because there
are already
so many really good harry potter style
ones out there already i mean just think
about it over the years between the
books and movies we have seen
numerous different styles we've even got
replicas of the movie ones that have
already been released
if you can ever make it down to the
wizarding world in orlando florida then
you can even get a
personalized wand from ollivanders so at
least for me if they were to include a
wand as part of the collector's edition
then it likely wouldn't come anywhere
close to matching the quality of these
other wands that we've been able to
purchase over the years
now if you can't get enough hogwarts
legacy content i have a full playlist
for you here on the right side of the
screen
and if you're in the mood for some old
school harry potter let's plays then you
can check out the link on the left side
of your screen
as always thank you all so much for
watching i'll talk to you again soon